this episode of the minimalist is
brought to you by
nobody because advertisements suck
this podcast has bad words
hello everybody welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less
my name is joshua fields milburn and i'm
ryan nicodemus and together we are the
minimalists today we're going to talk
about that empty feeling we all
experience from time to time and
the things we do to try to fill
the void we're going to do that with our
returning champion
jeanette mccurdy's here yeah welcome
thank you so happy to be here yeah
thanks for coming back yeah
last time we were sort of talking about
toxic fame when you were on here
since then you've launched a podcast i
want to talk to you a bit about the
podcast which is called empty
inside and so on this minimal version
today we're going to be
talking about that empty feeling that i
think we all experience from time to
time
how we can sort of form a dayton with
that but then on the maximal i do want
to talk to you about
filling the void in the different ways
some healthy unhealthy ways maybe
they're all unhealthy ways
that we try to fill the void talk to me
about that
that episode the title of your podcast
empty inside it's kind of exactly what
you're talking about it's definitely it
started from this place of
god we all feel that feeling we all get
empty
and we all try and desperately fill that
void with one thing or another what's
healthy what's not healthy i've
definitely
used my fair share of unhealthy coping
filling mechanisms and i'm working
toward
trying to find healthier filling
mechanisms every day
it seems to me that we were on your
podcast yeah and thank you guys for
coming on that was so fun it was such a
great conversation
yeah in fact it sparked an essay that i
shared with you
that will probably read on the maximal
but
uh right now i want to talk to you about
that empty feeling because i think
sometimes where we go
is we think well i'm gonna fill this
void with
sort of healthier things and and right
now we just try to fill the void right
you know ryan and i we tried to fill the
void with stuff
and when that didn't work we tried to
fill the void with success
and we felt empty and yet it was like
well i just haven't had enough success
or enough money or enough achievements
enough trophies enough trinkets right
yeah and and so we don't really know
what enough is but it's certainly more
than what we have right now
but i think that manifests in other ways
as well how did that manifest for you
my biggest one was excuse me i had
eating disorders for 13 years
and it was this constant chase of
feeling like if i could just
have a better eating disorder have the
right eating disorder for example
i had bulimia and when i had bulimia i
wanted to have anorexia
so unhealthy it makes me so sad now i
feel like i wasted my life i feel like
or
13 years of it um although i guess i can
say you know i learned some things and
definitely wouldn't go back there and
who knows where i'd be if i hadn't had
that uh trying experience but i
i definitely feel like that was my main
coping mechanism
yeah is it because um it was like this
sense of control that you had a hundred
percent okay
it was all about control for me i felt
like everything else in my life was
either my mother's decision or my
manager's decision decision or my
agent's decision or the network's
decision i feel like there were so many
people in my life
making every decision for me i really
felt like i had no
authority over myself and i think that
the control over my food and body or the
control that i felt like i had was the
thing that made me feel like
i can at least control this yes
interesting so to me it sounds like the
void
was uh in in this sense was uh the lack
of
choices that you felt like you had yeah
interesting
yeah it just makes me think how that
void can come from many different places
and if we look at the void as like a
symptom
then we can kind of maybe dig deeper
into well why are we experiencing
that void um yeah everyone experiences
it for different reasons
well ours is a listener driven show i
thought we'd dive into some questions
here we have one from instagram ryan
veronique
all right despite our higher
quality of life the void remains we live
richer lives materialistically
yet we feel more empty why
what is the disconnect between our way
of life
and happiness so i don't think that
we're chasing happiness i think
happiness is actually the chase of
happiness is one of the problems and
you experience this with how do i get
the better eating disorder
even when you say that out loud you
realize the absurdity of it
but it's the same thing with our stuff
it was like well i have
a lexus that's not really doing it for
me so how do i have
well two lexuses make me happy right and
it was like well i thought so
but why did i think so so so where does
this
come from i mean i think ultimately it
comes from society and culture and we
can sort of talk about the difference
between the two
you can't change your society we're all
sort of steeped in society unless you do
the ted kaczynski thing and
sort of move into a cabin in the middle
of nowhere which ryan and i tried
performing which we actually did do
um why did you guys do that but we were
productive we uh
well one might say that he was too well
i feel like he was running from the void
where we were embracing it
i mean yeah yeah or maybe he was he you
know there there
he had a lot of mental issues that i
think were actually caused by
by the society he was steeped in
initially right and so
we did this back in 2012 we moved out to
middle montana middle of nowhere
cabin on the side of a mountain sort of
as a reset it was a cool experiment i
wouldn't want to do that in perpetuity
and so when i say society it's just
society writ large our culture we sort
of get to determine our culture although
most of us don't actually
do it we don't do it willingly it is
thrust upon us so
it's our peer group right if we're at a
school or if
you happen to be on a television show
all of a sudden that becomes
the culture in which you are
acculturated into
and do you think that society and
culture in your life
it played a role in some of those
disorders i definitely think i think
being in hollywood period you know just
from a very young age you're
told these things of like oh well if you
look younger for your age you'll book
more roles and you're hearing that at
nine so you're thinking well if i can
look six
that'll be that'll help my career oh my
god so it's like
that was definitely a contributing
factor to anorexia for sure which i i
first developed when i was 11. wow
wow and so so i think that we have all
of these influences around this and
many many of the times it's sort of well
intentioned and so if i go back to
veronik's question here the disconnect
between our way of life
and happiness the the disconnect is
actually the chase the chase for
happiness so that's always leads to some
sort of
yeah you you find the void pretty
quickly there
when you understand that oh wait a
minute as i'm chasing happiness the
thing that i'm actually getting from it
is misery i thought
that the things would bring me more joy
more contentment
but they're bringing the opposite it's
not peace it's chaos
and we go searching for peace as though
peace can be acquired
but you never acquired peace peace is
already sort of there and what we do is
we
we cover it up with our own proclivities
our own desire to control everything
i know as well when i was a child you
know ryan i had both
both had dysfunctional households
growing up and
and the need for control was pretty
dramatic i felt like i didn't have
control for anything
and and therefore i would control
anything that i could i developed ocd as
a kid
as a result he had the cleanest room a
fifth grader
has ever had i remember how nice and
tidy and clean your room always was
that's wild yeah so so yet we feel more
empty she says we live richer lives
materialistically
yeah we're wealthier now like even your
average
person who grew up poor like us right
you think about us growing up poor
or someone who's in that circumstance
especially now in 2021
that person has more wealth
material wealth than kings from the
1800s
they have they can have air conditioning
or just electricity yeah
a phone that yeah bathrooms oh my god
yeah and so you have you have all of
this
stuff but it actually the problem is
there that we're trying to
fill the void with some stuff we have a
question here from em on facebook um
okay let me say one thing about uh
veronique's question um i feel like
in the question she talks about we we're
more rich than ever
we have a higher quality of life than
ever what is the disconnect and for me
when you put the when you put your
well-being
uh not your well-being but your your
sense of self i guess
on your quality of life i mean that's
kind of the problem right where
you think well well man i should be
happy because i have an indoor bathroom
and i have a decent sized bank account
so why am i not happy
but the problem might be because you're
leaning on those things to
uh to fill that void well maybe
challenge the question here then
jeanette yes we do have a higher quality
of life materialistically but i would
argue that we don't have a higher
quality of life we sort of have the
opposite
we have a lower quality of life we are
sicker
than ever before uh as a society you
know
in terms of chronic illness and disease
stress anxiety
how is that a higher quality of life it
seems to me that it isn't so
ostensibly you had the perfect life and
people saw it and they're like oh
that's what i want but you didn't want
it no absolutely not and
actually a big thing that i did to help
my mental health was i quit acting
and it was a thing that everyone in my
circle was saying
why would you quit this like you know
people work so hard to have any
degree of success you you're you can't
quit your career this is
such a stupid decision even my family
members were saying things like that
and i just knew that i had to do it i
knew that it was
not serving me anymore and it was
definitely difficult it wasn't an easy
thing it wasn't like oh i just call my
agent and say oh i'm done
it definitely took months of of gaining
up the courage to be able to walk away
from something like that
and it's it was also very confusing for
me because i felt like that should be a
thing that
should make me happy i was successful at
a career that
is hard to be successful at but it was
really really
uh unpleasant and and quite frankly
damaging for me
i see a lot of parallels between her
story and ours right
because the same thing happened when we
walked away from the corporate world
it was oh my god you've spent 12 years
climbing the corporate ladder you're
right you're crazy yeah yeah
and in fact a lot of people who said you
were crazy they had some sort of tie
to that they felt that our success
also tied them to success in some way
so i'm sure you saw that not just with
parents and family but people around you
i want to be
a friend with this quote unquote
successful person yes
let's talk about that uh yeah i
definitely lost some friends
like it was very telling uh who was sort
of
you know less available or less
interested uh it it was
it was very telling so it's almost like
a blessing in disguise right
it's like you get to find out who your
friends are immediately that's the same
thing that happened when
we called ourselves the minimalists i
mean we found out really quickly who our
true friends were it's amazing though
it's i would so much rather have a few
really great friends and know
that those friendships are trusted and
true then have
you know dozens or hundreds whatever how
many friends you can you have but like
you know
excessive where they just they aren't
really that impactful
yeah they become acquaintances used to
always tell me she's like one day
because my cousin and i uh when we were
i don't know the second third fourth
grade something
we were comparing how many friends we
had i don't even know why we were doing
this but i remember having this
conversation we're sitting there we're
listing all our friends
and my grandma was like you kids are
crazy like when you get to be my age
you'll be lucky
if you can uh you know just count a
number of good friends on one hand
she was like trust me you'll realize
when you get older and it's one of those
things as a kid you're like yeah yeah
whatever
but i had you know i went to a birthday
party and there were 15 kids there and
they're
all my friends um but yeah uh it's true
it's absolutely true it's like one of
those things
that when you're young you don't
understand but as i'm older i'm like oh
yeah like it is on one hand
that i can count like my really true
awesome friends i have a lot of
acquaintances
sure and a lot of people i hang out with
but you know people that i could
you know ask to uh help me hide a dead
body i mean
[Laughter]
i can count those people on one hand how
old were you when you wrote the the
friend
or when you were going over your friends
with your friends with my cousin
i think it was 38 yeah right exactly
this is just like a couple months ago no
this
i was probably in the fourth grade i
feel like it's a thing at that age i
remember i
i saw a journal entry of mine when i was
like probably probably around the same
age
and i listed out all my friends from
church and then i also listed ryan
seacrest as a friend of mine
because i had like played his daughter
for the day on his radio show
which is like very generous to give
somebody who you spent two hours with
one day who doesn't remember your name
the label a friend
yeah that's crazy i think ryan c
seacrest is a friend to all
he's america's friend that's right he's
american
if i was him that would definitely be my
twitter bio america's friend america's
friend
oh it's so good yeah although i will say
this and and jeanette you you read our
book you were so gracious and gave us a
really great blurb i love
the book so much i let you guys went
deeper into your own kind of backgrounds
and childhoods than i'd ever seen you go
and i was
all about it thank you the book is
called love people use things you can
pre-order right now it does help us out
a lot love people use things.net
and you can even check out jeanette's um
blurb i think it'll be up on the sales
page as well by the time this comes out
now
i will say this in there we talk about
the three different types of
relationships
in our life the sort of primary
relationships you can usually count
those on one hand as ryan is indicating
here
two if you're mormon or catholic
yeah yeah and um and then you have like
the secondary relationships these are
your
co-workers and friends and and and more
distant family
and it's not that one group is better
than the other
it's just we misprioritize our
friendships as you alluded to because we
have this tertiary group or what we call
the peripheral
relationships and you know there could
be a hundred people especially for
extroverts like ryan he probably has 100
150 people in that periphery
and and that's not wrong the problem in
my own life is i was prioritizing those
people
you know ryan seacrest was getting all
of my attention
and and the people closest to me were
the people i forsook and the problem
with that is
they often understand short term right
oh you're off just being successful and
but long term there's a resentment or a
discontent that builds
and and because every relationship sort
of has that us box in the middle of us
and and when i stopped giving to the us
box and i'm still taking from it
what is that going to lead to it's
always going to lead to resentment in
some way
do you feel like any of your
relationships there were people who were
taking a whole lot from that box and and
not giving or were you ever that person
um i definitely think my mom took
from that box for sure like 100 percent
that that's
that was the most uh difficult and
closest relationship of my
entire life by far um i'm trying to
think if there's an example
in probably more so in relationships in
like intimate relationships i'm the
taker
of the box and then in friendships i'm
definitely like
i i want there to be more space like i
wish there would there was less
does that make sense yeah yeah like i
think i'm more needy in relation in
intimate relationships and in
friendships i'm like
that it's fine where do you think that
stems from uh
you tell me i wish i knew and i'm
working on it and i would like
for this to be better yeah yeah i mean
this probably has something to do with
expectations right um
in terms of whenever we ask for
something from someone
it is because we expect that it should
be a particular way
and in fact you know we heavily moralize
everything in our culture especially
american or western culture where
you know we say you you you should do
this or you shouldn't do that or
or you know you you should eat this
particular way and not eat this way
and and i think in our relationships
that's also true where it's like
you you're supposed to behave a
particular way well
i'm inventing that way there's no
natural way there's a natural order for
a
a intimate or monogamous relationship in
in our
in our lives in fact that's you know we
had a guest on recently was talking
about how
it was sort of a invention of the uh the
catholic church around the fourth
century
um and not to say that it's wrong or
that we shouldn't do that but like
understanding like wait a minute this
isn't the natural order the way things
are supposed to be
we are we're determining oh wait here
are my expectations i'm
thrusting them on to you and therefore
i'm going to be discontented every time
you don't meet these expectations right
right yeah when it's an invisible
expectation like that wasn't set up
and i remember actually in one episode
you mentioned something with your wife
about
uh phone calls or or setting the
expectation that you i think you're not
a phone talker is that
correct yeah it's true and that stuck
out at me is so
like i think that's so important to
relationships is setting that
expectation early on
and going like this is what i'm
comfortable with this is what i'm not
comfortable with so that it's not this
like learning curve this jolt of a
learning curve
every time you come to those bumps in
the road where it's like oh we
completely have different expectations
here
yeah it's like if josh never said that
to bex
and she would call him and try to talk
to him on the phone and he's constantly
being short with her and pushing her off
right and then eventually you know he's
like yeah you need to stop calling me i
don't like that well
bex didn't know you didn't like that
yeah so to set those expectations up
front is so important because
you can't thrust an expectation on
someone if they have no
idea of your expectation that you have
yeah
it's amazing and that's that uh you you
that anecdote on the podcast
has helped my boyfriend tonight
tremendously uh thank you
that sort of set the stage for us to say
our expectations
early on um i shared with him that clip
of the podcast and he was like this is
incredible this is how we should be
operating and so that's
now anytime something comes up for us
we'll be like oh this is what i expect
or this is how i kind of operate and
this is what's comfortable for me and we
just get it out ahead of time
it's saved us i think so much drama have
you ever read
some thoughts about relationships by
colin wright no it's uh
my favorite relationship book and uh in
there it's
each chapter is a really short one or
two page policy it's like a relationship
policy that he has in his own life and
so one in there for example is the i
will tell you policy
and because i don't know if you ever do
this but um in
most of my relationships like if
something feels a little bit off usually
it's me but like i'm projecting on to
them and
what's the first thing i'll say is
everything okay yeah
and uh i mean i don't know if you've
experienced that is everything okay
and then you run around all day saying
that four or five times
and really all i'm saying is hey
something's not okay with me
yeah and and now i'm i'm thrusting that
onto you and so the i will tell you
policy is one example of like hey if
something's wrong i will tell you
and and even now like if it comes up bex
will be
like hey is everything okay yes i will
tell you if it's not
but the the flip side of that is i have
to be honest about that if something is
up
i do have to be willing to have that
conversation and not wait until
it blows up i have to be willing to say
yes i will tell you if something is off
and it leads to some more difficult
conversations in the short term
but never any explosions as a result
right
yeah it's a phenomenal book i i
recommend it to everyone
megan in boston has a question for us
i found it hard to describe to people my
views because they are too
caught up in the rat race to slow down
and think with me
i'm curious to know if you have some
suggestions on good
elevator pitch style descriptions of
this minimalist lifestyle
something to get someone interested in
sitting down and thinking and
talking with me so jeanette megan has
this interesting question
when you were first exposed to
minimalism i don't know that anyone gave
you an elevator pitch necessarily
i can understand you know my elevator
pitch is simple minimalism is the thing
that gets us past the things
and and if you because that really opens
up the door for conversation but what
really opened it up like when ryan came
to me i never jumped up and said i'm a
minimalist you need to be a minimalist
too
because that doesn't work that's why i'm
mormon and now you need to be mormon as
well right right
it's like well no i i i'm not trying to
convert ryan
into minimalism normally i was always
trying to convert you into being a
jehovah's witness
that is true yeah yeah i remember your
dad used to like do
watchtower studies with me and my
brother and oh my god um
anyway uh you you stumbled into
minimalism other people have asked you
about this thing
called minimalism how have you
approached it with other people
um i let me think
i'm trying to think if there's a
i don't have a i don't have a short sort
of answer here it's always like here
watch this documentary
right yeah i mean sure the thing is i
i i like i like this answer because it's
not really about trying to convince
anyone of anything and and i think
that's
too often what we want to do even a
moment ago i said i recommend colin's
book i don't actually mean that i don't
want you to read it i'm not trying to
convince you to read it what i'm really
saying is
it was helpful for me and because it was
helpful for me
it may or may not be helpful for other
people in fact
bex and i sat down and read that book
chapter by chapter when we first started
dating and it helped us
set some ground rules and some
expectations have some conversations
and i think the same thing can be true
with minimalism or any other way of
living in fact
minimalism sounds like an ideology
because it's ism right it means the
ideology of less
in a way but to me it's the only ism
without an ideology because we're not
prescribing
anything and i'm certainly not tr
proselytizing i'm not trying to
convince you that this is the best way
to live it may not be especially if
you're contented with the status quo
i found a lot of people are discontented
by the status quo
and and that's you know we often say
this podcast
welcomes anybody but it's not for
everybody
and and because of that oh because of
that
it is it's clear that i'm not saying you
should do this you should be a
minimalist you should be a minimalist
i i don't really have a definitive
elevator pitch my elevator pitch is
always when someone asks about it
then i can answer questions that they
have about their own curiosity
yeah actually now that i think about it
back toward the beginning of when i was
first finding out about it and so
intrigued by the
ideas behind it uh i didn't tell really
anybody they just knew that i was
getting rid of a bunch of my stuff and
then i sold my house and
it was sort of i think it was confusing
for them and i
maybe i actually felt some shame around
it because it was so different from what
everybody in
my social circle sort of was used to and
and
you know my friends would come and be
like you can't be getting rid of this or
like those shoes are expensive or like
whatever you know the thought would be
and i think now it's a much more
familiar topic and i think people are
much more kind of comfortable discussing
it and
everybody's at least heard of it and in
some way shape or form and so now i feel
like it's a much more
exciting time to be able to open that
conversation and have it with people
versus like i don't know 10 years ago or
whatever when it was a bit more
under the radar you know it's funny you
mentioned shane because i've never
talked about this but i think i
i felt some shame early on around it as
well really yeah
because you know the world ryan and i
were in it was
you know it was achievement and it was
uh wanting more it was always wanting
more and in fact
it was sort of it was a parody of
wanting more
in a way right it was a wolf of wall
street but it was like two degrees
below that where it was a lot of boys
club
a lot of um men
white men in particular who were in
positions of power
and the thing i've learned recently is
power is sort of the obverse of freedom
in a way but by by getting
or or wanting or maintaining power
we actually give up freedom and we take
other people's freedom
as well but having power having dominion
over someone
means they're not free to make all of
their own decisions and
ryan and i had a lot of power i managed
150 retail stores with
plenty of employees and i realized like
i had
some sort of dominion over those people
and in a way
i was responsible for draining bits of
their freedom and how did i justify that
well by
saying that i was successful that i was
living my best life and and i was doing
what i was
supposed to do moralizing it as well and
so
when i when i was doing what i was
supposed to do
if i did something that was the opposite
of that like minimalism
it was like oh this is not what i'm
supposed to do and there's shame around
there right
anytime we feel like we're doing
something that we're not supposed to do
then we're going to feel that shame yeah
yeah and i i assume that shame is
manifested in different ways for you
especially with
the eating disorder stuff but then also
even the walking away from
that career that you had there's some
shame in there and
it could be other people shaming you
telling you it's the wrong thing to do
but then also i think there's a lot of
self-talk there we tell ourselves it's
the wrong thing to do
and for the first few years after those
major life decisions
i started doubting myself very intensely
and thinking well did i just do those
things
was this all just were these all just
repercussions to my mom dying like did i
just quit acting
because it was what my mom wanted me to
do should i have stayed with with it did
i just
leave the house because of my mom like
is this all just because of my mom did i
make
not only one but like every possible big
life decision mistake all at the same
time and
especially when there was no success
sort of backing up the new
career that i was pursuing it was like
well i just [ __ ]
everything up i just threw my life away
for what
and it was very very difficult and then
you know sort of little by little
i gained confidence i guess just maybe
with the
maybe it's just a self-trust thing you
know i didn't i didn't have any external
validation at that point in my life
but i think it was an important phase
for me to go through to sort of find
some of that self-trust
because i don't think i had really any
before making those decisions and facing
those uh
demons for lack of a better term yeah i
think that confidence probably came from
consistency
like whenever we whenever we make that
major life change there's always going
to be a little bit of doubt it's going
to you know it's it's
untested waters but once we get enough
consistency
of that new way of living yeah that's
where i think the confidence really
really comes in
so interesting that's that seems
definitely true i do want to talk about
that self-trust also i want to talk
about self-care to a great extent we're
going to talk about that on the maximum
also you know that i think
success does not exist and we're going
to talk about that as well
because i do think that we get so caught
up in this idea of success but i think
all success is failure and i know that
sounds like a so interesting
a bold statement but we have an essay we
could talk about but also you and i had
a conversation about this on your
podcast i want to go deeper on that
but before we do that ryan what time is
it you know what time it is it is time
for our lightning round where we answer
your text messages
text your questions and comments to
937-202-4654 yeah ryan and i
both of those those those texts go to
both of our phones
we respond to a lot of people um we
don't respond to everyone we just can't
but
uh we do respond to some folks here on
the podcast now janette you probably
remember that during
the lightning round this is where ryan
and i and our guests we do our best to
answer questions with a short shareable
less than 140 character response
we put the text to these minimal maxims
in the show notes so you can copy and
share our pithy answers on
social media if you like and now you can
find all of our minimal maxims in one
place thanks to jess
um that place is minimal maxims.com
really can we can ramble on it but you
don't have to have 140 characters
i try to be a minimalist but not with
like talking podcast will make it look
really nice
yeah he makes everything tweetable yeah
all right audra's got a
question here i'd like to hear more
about suggestions of things people
should do uh oh
yes filling our voids with stuff isn't
good but what is good
there's a lot of words here that are um
yes yeah
the urge to consume needs to be replaced
by something else
meaningful okay so so let's just say
this um there are a lot of words here
that you've been acculturated to believe
right and so you've been taught
that stuff is going to make you happy
and then you've been taught the
well no it's not the stuff that's gonna
make you happy it has to be something
else here's my pithy answer and then we
can we can sort of uh
riff on it a bit chasing the good binds
us to the bad
and so whenever we're looking for well
what's the good alternative to this
i'm now tethering myself to the bad side
of things when i say
i'm when i'm denouncing or renouncing
stuff i'm forever tied to it instead of
renouncing stuff i can simply
not renounce i can walk away from the
attachment i can be non-attached to
stuff because ryan and i still have
stuff i
clearly am not an ascetic i you know we
have microphones and clothes
and and and couches and um and and what
i've
recognized here is that as soon as
because at first
especially when i felt that shame early
on i thought that minimalism
i was confused minimalism was about
renouncing my stuff
well no we're not monks right
it's not it's not about getting rid of
all of our things it's about
an understanding and understanding the
things i thought were going to make me
happy are
actually the objects of my discontent
they're making me
miserable it doesn't mean i have to let
go of everything it just means that
the the act of letting go of the
attachment
will make room for something else now
audra's question is
what is that something else she says the
urge to consume
needs to be replaced by something else
meaningful
i think that's a mistake and you
recognize this early on when you left
that
acting career what do i replace
that with and you say well and then i
replace it with something
that's not making me happy either well
it's not making me successful
either i think the success is going to
lead me to happiness
and and of course the void remains
what stands out to me is the the words
should
the words good in the words needs which
is really just another way to
say should and for all intents and
purposes
and josh and i have talked about this a
lot um over the last few podcasts about
there really are no
shoulds and that's probably where
i used to get stuck a lot because
well really going back to uh vern
veronique's question veronique's
question where
you know i thought to myself well i've
got a nice job title
i get to go on vacations i have a new
car i have a house
um you know my dating life is great
i should be happy people would kill to
be in this position i should be
appreciative of this
and those shoulds are really what kind
of um prevented me from
exploring different uh ways of life
it just it limited me to what i what i
could do
because i had all these shoulds and then
you know good
is really perspectival right i mean
you um are perspectival it's it's really
difficult to just look at something and
say well that is a hundred percent
good um i don't know uh what do we mean
when we say
good right we it's either moralizing the
thing as in
it is the right thing to do right and
that's what i'm seeing here right uh
we need to fill up with the right things
we right the wrong things and then the
right things and
and i own the wrong things but if i just
own the right things
then i'll be happy well no no no
happiness is only uncovered it's never
acquired and so i think there's
something about
forming a data with the void yeah which
actually is a good segue into my uh
tweetable answer okay what do you got
which is fill the void with acceptance
not stuff
so there's there's always going to be a
void i feel like
yes and really that's the human
condition because if we didn't have that
void
we wouldn't be inspired or motivated to
do anything greater than just uh you
know
feed ourselves house ourselves and uh
you know reproduce
yes um but there is this void that
drives us to do things like
go to the moon or explore space or
explore whatever it is
that those um things that you see us
exploring that's all because there's a
void
that we are trying to not fill per se
but
i mean i guess we are trying to fill up
we are but but but it's like it's a
motivating factor so
you know uh the men's team that i'm on
they talk about the suck hole
a lot the suck hole
and uh josh let's keep this mature
wait a minute but but think about like a
think about like a um
they couldn't affect any better no
think about like uh uh you're like a
drain okay
so at the bottom is that is that suck
hole
where it's it's sucking everything down
yes and i i
i'm not gonna sit here and try to list
out each level because it's like a
sinkhole
i'd be paraphrasing yeah sinkhole you
can call it that too um
so whatever makes you not giggle and
smart i'm trying to
i'm trying to imagine this as a as a
metaphor yeah absolutely i've never
heard of a suck hole i've heard of a
sinkhole it is it is a metaphor so
um there are different levels and you
know if you're at the top
and like you're constantly getting
dragged down but what we can stay at the
top
if we are doing things like you know our
short-term actions aligning with
our values if we are you know
contributing beyond ourselves in
meaningful ways
and there are different levels and the
whole idea is
to avoid getting sucked down the drain
essentially
let me let me say this jeanette i think
that
when we when you hear a question like
this it presupposes one thing that we
are yet to mention and we're gonna
probably spend the next hour or so
talking about this uh on the maximal but
here's here's where i want to go
right now to wrap this up we presuppose
that the void is bad
right that the emptiness is bad but
think about this for a moment let's
extend that metaphor when what are some
of the most beautiful places on earth
you go into a
if even if it's man-made like a museum
they're relatively empty
compared to most spaces we go in it's
beautiful now it's curated
and it appears to be mostly empty
but we enjoy that emptiness in fact it
removes the chaos
now what about natural voids the grand
canyon comes to mind
yeah now imagine if i went to the grand
canyon how do i fill this
and i've got an idea i'll fill it with
water well that's what's
happened it just widens the void it
makes the canyon
wider right right it extends and so we
try to fill the void and it always
widens it whenever we try to to fill it
with stuff or achievements or whatever
it is
and so i like your answer because it's
sort of a double entendre like we can
accept other people we can respect them
but we can also accept
respect and appreciate the void the
emptiness
and what i like about your podcast it
seems to be an exploration of
that emptiness in a way not to fix it
but to better understand it to form a
day taunt with it because if we can do
that
if we really understand the emptiness we
can realize like
oh this isn't a bad thing i don't have
to fill it my culture has simply told me
that it's supposed to be filled because
i fill the grand canyon
i'm actually going to decrease its
beauty in a way 100 that's actually
partially why i named it empty inside i
like to name thing
i like to name any of my projects with
titles that are sort of
offensive or that seem prickly or seem
scary or seem one way
and then if you just give it a chance
you just give it a couple minutes of
your time hopefully
you find out that there was actually a
different intention behind it you did a
one-woman
show can you give me the title of that
i'm glad my mom died oh thanks for
coming ryan that was so nice of you to
come
you were sitting front row and it just
made the whole thing so much more
enjoyable for me
that's awesome yeah yeah and so there is
something about that where you
you jab someone and it's not in the
click-baity way and i'm so grateful you
don't do that but it's in a way that
that evokes a particular emotion it
makes me feel
one way yeah and then it's like well the
same thing with empty inside
yeah we're all empty and that's okay
yeah that's where the beauty is with
minimalism the bones are the beauty
we get down to the essence of the thing
where the form matters so much less
when you get down to the the essence
it's it's a particular kind of
the simplicity is is elegant in a way
and unfortunately we just complicate
it by trying to fill the grand canyon
yeah or trying to fill the art museum
with all the stuff
then all of a sudden it's not art
anymore it's just trash yeah i mean yeah
i feel like and i
was totally guilty of this i just spent
all my time figuring out
okay what can i put in that sinkhole
that is going to stop it from stop me
from sinking
and like you said like it's nothing is
going to fill it completely
um you can't fill the grand canyon you
can fill it with air maybe right but
even then
yeah it's full and the thing is when you
show up to the grand canyon
it's all inspiring yeah you respect it
yes it's and you wouldn't even have the
thought
of trying to fill it but if everyone
told you you were supposed to fill it
then all of a sudden yeah i guess i know
this seems daunting
and it would be daunting it's trying to
fill the grand canyon you're not going
to fill it
and we need to find explore ways to
become
comfortable in that emptiness we're
going to talk about that a lot more
but first we have some voicemail
comments and insights from our listeners
check them out
hello this is larry from brazil and i
would like to share my experience with
leaving facebook i once had 5 000
facebook friends
because i believed this would bring me
more business it did not
these people were collecting me like one
more pin for the pinterest board of
friends
as was i so i started to unfriend them
one by one and once i got to only people
i actually knew
i still had over 400 friends
there's no way that keeping in touch
with 400 people
would add value to my life so i decided
to ignore the potential backlash
and unfriend until i was down to close
friends only
and guess what there was zero backlash
because
these people did not actually care about
me as much as
i did not actually care about them the
next step
seemed so obvious to me all my close
friends have my number
so why not limit these interactions to
actual conversations
and delete facebook altogether it's been
over a year and i never looked back
hey guys so i have been trying to live a
more sustainable
and ethical life and that is how i came
across your podcast
on many episodes and especially the one
about clothing you guys discuss
buying things responsibly and suggested
a few companies that share your values
i wanted to share how this can be
applied not just to things but also with
everyday
consumable items that obviously you
cannot buy
secondhand such as cleaning supplies
beauty bath and body items skin care and
many other
many of the standard companies that you
find in stores
don't have the most sustainable or
ethical practices
most cleaning or beauty brands use dirty
palm oil
others use harsh chemicals and
many other things so this has led me to
discover and support
smaller businesses so for example i buy
natural the other end
lotions and all my bath
items from an etsy shop there are many
out there i just picked the one closest
to me
and it's all natural and homemade i buy
my dishwashing and laundry detergent
from drops
that's spelled d-r-o-p-p-s
it gets shipped to my house and you can
look on their website about their
awesome
social and environmental responsibility
it is also plastic free it's just little
pods that come
in a box my favorite
brand is my toilet paper and paper towel
brand they're called
who gives a crap it is a bit more pricey
but they donate 50
of their profits to building toilets in
the third world
in third world countries uh where lack
of sewage systems affects
health and many children die from this
so
it is a great way to help by doing
something as simple as well
wiping your butt plus their emails are
always funny with the toilet puns and
they make
reports showing their latest donations
and impacts
those are just a few of my favorite
alternatives there are many more out
there if you do your research
so if you can don't just focus
responsible purchasing to clothes and
things but also to
everyday things all right y'all we got a
bunch more surprise
questions for our maximal episode this
thursday on
patreon but first real quick for right
here right now here's
one thing that's going on in the life of
the minimalists ryan sometimes when you
watch something it becomes binge-worthy
right you hear this term
binge-worthy it means you can sit down
and watch all the episodes at once
yeah well thankfully we have a new
binge-worthy
series on youtube it's called let's talk
about less it's a six episode series and
you can seriously sit down and binge
these because all the episodes are like
three four
five minutes long max and jordan
directed these he did such a phenomenal
job with the typefacing and the music
and the ambiance
the series is called let's talk about
less and really what we do is
it's a video essay series that explores
a specific problem that was created by
consumerism so
there's things like let's talk about
minimalism is the very first episode
let's talk about the economy let's talk
about technology let's talk about social
media let's talk about
debt yeah and with each one of these
problems we really talk about the
problem behind
the problem because it often feels like
well too much stuff is the problem and
that's true
but what is the problem behind that
problem what we do is we examine that
it's called let's let's
let's talk about less and you can find
it over at youtube.com
the minimalist it's right there on the
main page you can binge watch
all six episodes from the first season
ryan for our added value this week have
you been listening to justin bieber's
new album no you know you were playing
it oh that's right we went hiking
yeah you were playing and on the way to
hiking and uh
oh it was so cute to hear ella like
singing to it that was adorable
it was but i haven't listened to it
since i totally forgot about it yeah
well
the song i want to play out today is is
lonely from the new album the album's
called justice by the way
and since we're really talking about the
emptiness
the emptiness inside especially on the
maximum episode we're going to talk
about
the void well what does that make us
feel quite often it makes us feel lonely
yeah and one of the things you see in a
song like
lonely by justin bieber is oh
all of this so-called success is
incredibly
isolating yeah and it creates a new kind
of emptiness
so let's listen to lonely from justin
bieber's new album
justice by the way we have a bunch more
surprise questions this week like
why do we eat so much how do we fill
that void with something
other than food people often feel empty
as a result of fewer
social connections or relationships that
feel one-sided
what can we do to foster new empowering
relationships
how does one encourage their mom to
declutter
what language can we use that is
compassionate and not insulting
plus we have a million more questions
for jeanette and the minimalist and if
you want to hear all that
join us on the minimalist private
podcast this thursday
visit theminimalists.com support to
subscribe to our patreon
and you'll get a personal link so that
our private podcast plays
in your favorite podcast app it keeps
our show
100 advertisement free you can follow
the minimalists on facebook twitter and
instagram
at the minimus come to one of our live
podcast shows
visit the minimalists.com tour to find a
city near you
if you have a question comment or
minimalism tip for our podcast email a
voice memo to
podcast at theminimalists.com if you
want our show notes in your inbox sign
up for our email list over at the
minimalists.com you'll also receive any
new minimalist writings
for free right there in your inbox and
if you leave here today with just
one message let it be this love people
and use things because the opposite
never works
thanks for listening y'all we'll see you
next time
[Music]
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing that's just feeding
your greed oh i bet that you'll be fine
without it